is it
correct for people to have children
before marriage
um what's your view is it is it correct
for children for for people across
Scotland to have children outside of
marriage um it's it's not it's something
that I would
um seek to avoid for me personally but
it doesn't fuss me doesn't put me up or
down and the choices that other people
make is it right or is it is it right or
is it wrong in terms of my faith my
faith would say that children well if
there's Sexes for for marriage and
that's the approach that I would
practice but so is it in your view wrong
then for people to have children outside
of marriage that's your view
I mean you're asking me would I impose
my views on other people ultimately
that's what you're asking no I'm just
asking what your view is is that correct
you know in terms of me personally that
is the approach I would practice but
you're also asking me do I think that
some of my family who've done that are
wrong do I think that some of my friends
who've done that are wrong I I mean I
accept them I'm you know that's choices
that they've made and we either live in
a tolerant Society where I can celebrate
the birth of children
irrespective of the family or not and I
do celebrate those lives that have been
brought into the world but on a point of
principle you believe that and that's
wrong it's the same with a number of
other points you're probably going to
come on and ask me you're asking me what
would I do
not because I think it's Superior or
better but because it's in line with the
teachings of my faith which actually is
quite similar to most mainstream
religions you're asking what I would do
but then asking me would I take that in
to a legal or political context and
oppose it I I go to church on Sunday I'm
not sitting here thinking saying to you
you need to be going to church no but
people at this point this really pivotal
moment when it comes to the next first
minister of Scotland are Keen to hear
your views on this and are not seeing
whether it's right or wrong either way
I'm just asking you you think it's wrong
well I think for for me it would be
wrong according to my faith but for you
I have no idea what your faith is so in
a free Society you do what you want
let's look now at the case of gender
reform Scottish uh Parliament overall
overwhelmingly voted just before
Christmas for uh to make it easier for
people to change their legally
recognized gender system of of of
identity would you have voted for that
you were one of the heads of the
government would you have voted
previously said before a maternity leave
that I had significant concerns with
self-identification and I would continue
to have had those concerns it's often
difficult to use hypotheticals because I
would have obviously participated fully
in the process I'd have raised points of
concern and actually I think we did see
the bill getting more into the territory
of additional safeguards in terms of for
example uh young people needing to seek
additional counsel so I think there's
ways of building in further safeguards
but ultimately the aim is to ensure that
women feel like safe spaces can be
protected and the trans Community
um are not stigmatized will you block
um or will you go forward with a legal
challenge to the UK government
attempting to block what the Scottish
Parliament has passed I mean I think the
first point is the point of principle
and then the second is the point of of
in politics on a point of principle it
is outrageous that the UK government
should block any legislation
but right now we have a choice we're at
Crossroads do we either work as a
devolved government
to seek to amend the bill to make it
compatible or do we take it to court
and I think certainly most of the
pooling is showing that the people of
Scotland want us to focus on the
priorities of cost of living NHS so on
rather than take it to court in terms of
my personal view of the bill I think we
do need to look again at safeguards
particularly around young people and I
think that is is that you saying you
wouldn't like to see 16 17 17 17 year
olds included in this orbit safeguards
but just just to be clear and you talk
about straight talking at the start do
you are you in favor of 16 and 17 year
olds being part of this lady I would
have been far more supportive of it
being 18 year old so you don't support
16 and 17 year olds is that what you're
saying I am saying that but I think that
we also need to make sure that the the
whole process of support and making the
bill less sorry making the gender reform
uh act less onerous is also important
the first Minister was in a sugar peg in
recent weeks around trans prisoners uh
particularly the case of Isla Bryson the
double rapist
originally known as Adam Graham who
transitioned to trans women during those
very serious Court proceedings as Isla
Bryson in your view a man or a woman a
rapist cannot be a woman and therefore
my straight answer would be the Isle of
Brighton as a man